this square is one square unit so what
is the area of rectangle a the first
thing we're told is that each of these
little squares equal one square unit and
then we're asked to find the area of
rectangle a here's rectangle a an area
is the space that it covers so how much
space does rectangle a cover how many
square units does rectangle a cover one
way to answer that would be to count how
many square units it covers except
they've covered up our square units so
one idea is we could draw them back
say you cover them up we'll draw them
back in so going like this connect all
these and then we should be able to
count our square units so we have one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve twelve square units
rectangle a covers 12 square units so it
has an area of 12 square units but this
isn't the only way that we could have
solved this we could have also said we
could have also looked at this and said
okay this top row is 4 square units long
1 2 3 4 has a length of 4 units so that
means the top row will have 1 2 3 4
square units inside of it and then we
could have looked over on the side over
here and said well how many rows of four
will they'll be it'll be 1 2 3 rows of 4
so we'll have this row of 4 and then a
second row of 4 and a third so 3 times
we will have 4 square units there's 4
square units at the top another in the
middle and another at the bottom 3 times
we will have 4 square units or we could
go
and farther than that so we could have
said we could have done three times four
or we could look at this and say okay
here's one column this column has three
square units it has a length of three
one two three
how many of these columns like this will
there be it'll be one two three four
because our length here up at the top is
four so this time four times we will see
three square units one two three and
we'll see that one two three four times
so no matter which of these we solved
whether we counted the square units like
in the beginning or we multiplied the
side lengths the three and the four in
every case we're going to find that this
equals twelve square units the area of
rectangle a is twelve square units
because it covers twelve square units